[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture un
numéro spécialement consacré à la
réouverture du 19 mai dans les yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui si le domaine
de monte cristo avait déjà rouvert son
parc aux visites c'est au tour du
château d'être à nouveau accessible
après six mois de fermeture les
visiteurs vont pouvoir découvrir la
demeure d'alexandre dumas et des
événements sont d'ores et déjà prévues
le théâtre privé la royale factory à
versailles va rouvrir ses portes
vendredi 21 mai après des mois de
fermeture des spectacles sont programmés
en mai et en juin
rencontre sur place avec la directrice
du café théâtre et puis le parc france
miniature ouvre également le 21 mai un
lieu pour re découvrir les plus beaux
monuments français en miniature le parc
est prêt à retrouver son public et
accueillir les visiteurs dans de bonnes
conditions et je vous le disais en titre
visiter la demeure d'alexandre dumas au
château de monte-cristo de port marly
ce n'était plus possible depuis le 30
octobre dernier
si le parc avait ouvert aux visites
guidées de déconfinement du 19 mars 2021
marque la réouverture du château
un reportage de bixente mayence entité
ban et bérangère beau - principale
demeure de l'écrivain alexandre dumas le
domaine de monte cristo est composé du
château d'if et de son cabinet de
travail dès le 19 mai le château de
monte-cristo va rouvrir ses portes et
pouvoir accueillir de nouveau du public
avec une jauge la jauge dans le parc
n'est pas limité en revanche elle le
sera dans le château donc comme l'an
dernier quand on a rouvert en juin 2020
on a rouvert avec 30 personnes
autorisées en simultané dans le château
le parc du château avait déjà rouvert à
quelques privilégiés pour des visites
guidées sur réservation
par groupe de 5 maximum ses très bonnes
occasions parce que effectivement deux
personnes à voir le parc pour nous tout
seul c'était vraiment intéressant on
avait le temps de voir de discuter avec
la conférencière et de mieux comprendre
le cycle fermé depuis plus de six mois
la directrice du château a vu son nombre
de visites annuelles dégringolé en
principe sur une année on a entre 25000
et 30000 visiteurs sur une année là nous
sommes bientôt bientôt fin mais on en
aura eu zéro pour le moment pas non
peut-être avec les petites visites
quelques heures mais c'est vraiment rien
par rapport à la fréquentation
habituelle le château qui travaille avec
de nombreux artistes prévoit de les
retrouver rapidement le dimanche 13 juin
organise une après midi musical on va
avoir une harpiste qui va venir faire
différentes compositions et puis on aura
aussi un quartet de jazz manouche qui
sera présent tout va se passer dans le
parc
donc ça ira très bien sur le plan
sanitaire
un retour à la normale est donc prévue
pour le 19 mai puisque le château de
monte-cristo rouvrira selon les horaires
habituels du mardi au dimanche et
alexandrine la mascotte du domaine
attend les visiteurs nombreux et je
parlais bien évidemment du déconfinement
du 19 mai le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines comme beaucoup
rouvre ses portes au public donc dès le
20 mai avec une première jauge à 35%
un briefing a été opérée sur les
protocoles sanitaires à respecter les
équipes et les artistes sont prêts et
ont hâte d'accueillir à nouveau le
public
un premier spectacle est prévue les 20
et 21 mai à 19h30 au théâtre
il s'agit de la dispute le fait de
retrouver du public en salle c'est une
sensation très agréable
c'est marrant de recommencer avec avec
la dispute mais c'est un spectacle sur
le divorce
où sur les enfants sans père qui qui
vient de la parole mais qui est dit par
des enfants qui c'est la parole des
enfants en fait mohamed al khatib
le metteur en scène a travaillé avec des
enfants pendants entre 8 et 8 et 11 ans
pendant près d'une année pour les faire
en quelque sorte accoucher de ce qu'il
ressentait de vivre dans des familles
chacun dans des familles monoparentales
ne votre spectacle seront programmés
entre le 1er juin et le 2 juillet des
événements en plein air auront lieu au
courant juillet avec l'été culturel
programme et réservations via le lien à
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et parmi
les autres spectacles à venir les 25 26
et 27 mai le théâtre de sartrouville
vous propose de découvrir la pièce la
loi de la gravité un spectacle qui
questionne sur les notions d'identité et
de normes en mettant en scène deux
adolescents
plus d'informations sur le site du
théâtre et puis et le théâtre alexandre
dumas propose lui un concert jazz avec
l'artiste et trompettiste sylvain botach
l'événement aura lieu le jeudi 20 mai à
19 heures pour un concert d'une heure
environ et le théâtre privé la royale
factory à versailles va rouvrir ses
portes le vendredi 21 mai je vous disais
en titre après des mois de fermeture des
spectacles sont programmés en mai et en
juin
c'est lié à 400 go et belhani peau qui
ont rencontré la directrice du
café-théâtre regarder nous sommes devant
la scène de la royale factory à
versailles en compagnie de marie leur
boucher bonjour bonjour vous êtes la
directrice du café-théâtre lever de
rideau vendredi 21 mai après quasiment
un an de fermeture alors comment vous
organisez cette réouverture
bah tout d'abord on est très contents de
riblon le théâtre
on a dû aménager les horaires à cause du
couvre feu donc 19 heures les
représentations lieu de 20h30 ça fait un
petit peu tôt j'espère que les gens
pourront s'organiser pour venir nous
nous retrouver on a réduit notre jauge
donc on peut accueillir 60 personnes au
lieu de 180 donc y aura de la place il y
aurait des espaces et les avantages
qu'on a c'est qu'on a un centre de
traitement d'air donc en fait l'air est
renouvelée en continu fumant c'est pas
tous les ter qui avance à nous on a la
chance de l'avoir donc vous pouvez venir
en toute tranquillité qui ont été
assistés le spectacle est alors que
justement quelle est la programmation à
venir
alors donc on va démarrer le 21 donc à
19 heures avec karine dubernet donc
c'est un one woman show donc c'est une
artiste qui raconte sa vie en fait
donc elle va présenter toute une galerie
de personnages
c'est très drôle c'est très frais c'est
très dynamique sur vous invite à venir
découvrir ce spectacle des places
disponibles il y a de la place donc vous
pouvez acheter vos places ion2 site du
théâtre
ensuite on va enchaîner le week end
après avec une mauriste qui s'appelle à
maya qui est l'humoriste originaire des
yvelines qui parle de la normalité
donc comment être soi-même dont dans ce
monde
dans le monde actuel vous êtes un des
rares théâtre privé dans les yvelines
beaucoup ont été subventionnés justement
cette année vous en tant que théâtre
privé comment ça s'est passé
alors donc l'état a aussi mis en place
des aides pour les théâtres privés donc
la royale factory tient de bourges sera
toujours là donc elle nous a vraiment on
a vraiment bien été aidé donc on a pu
payer nos charges
évidemment on n'a pas gagné d'argent
cette année mais le théâtre sera
toujours là pour la rentrée vous avez
des aides de l'état
tout à fait elle ne fonctionne la
solidarité le chômage partiel donc ce
qui nous a permis de maintenir le
théâtre à flot voilà marie-laure boucher
d'avoir été notre avis des deux rien
versé le parc france miniature qui fête
ses 30 ans cette année
rouvre ses portes au public lui aussi le
vendredi 21 mai pour profiter des
attractions par contre il faudra
attendre encore le 9 juin un lieu pour
découvrir les plus beaux monuments
français en miniature tel que la tour
eiffel eux le château de versailles ou
encore le stade de france pour des
questions sanitaires le nombre de
personnes sur place sera limité il
faudra donc préservé pour venir
objectif du parc situé donc à elancourt
retrouver le public et accueillir les
visiteurs dans de bonnes conditions
l'essentiel c'est la déambulation
pouvoir tous les chefs d'oeuvre du
patrimoine français et puis et puis
aussi l interactivité avec des ateliers
interactifs sur le circuit de visite
donc l'essentiel le coeur du parc et
celui ci donc on pouvait réouvrir sur
lot d'attractions même si on est pressé
de revoir pour le
j'en ai l essence 117 plus beaux
monuments français qui sont représentées
sur une carte de france qui fait 5 ha
donc vu du ciel c'est exactement la
france qui représente et du nord au sud
et les monuments sont dans leur région
d'origine
et puis il ya tout un réseau de 15
trains qui circulent sur près de 3 km de
voies ferrées qui amuse beaucoup les
enfants qui courent après il a notamment
pour les enfants des petits cahiers jeux
interactifs aussi puisque comme il y
aura pas les autres actions qui puissent
aussi avoir un complément à leur visite
donc il ya un cahier jeu le petit
quotidien qui leur sera remis sur toute
la période et ça jusqu'à jusqu'à
l'ouverture des attractions l'unaf et si
vous cherchez d'autres idées de sorties
il y à des expositions à venir forcément
avec la couverture des musées le musée
de la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
par exemple vous accueille avec une
exposition temporaire
la ville a habité elle présenté
l'évolution du logement avec 25
opérations architecturale entre 1950 et
2000 sur l'agglomération
elle est accessible jusqu'au 24 juillet
prochain et puis autre idée de sortie le
palais du roi de rome musée d'art et
d'histoire de rambouillet vous propose
de découvrir trois grandes peintures à
l'adoration des bergers la vierge au
chapelet et la conversion de
saint-hubert ses tableaux seront
exceptionnellement visible de prêt
jusqu'au 30 mai puisque les peintures
sont habituellement conservées dans
l'église de renvoyer et coup d'envoi de
la quinzaine de la librairie jusqu'au 28
mai plus de 1300 élèves franciliens vont
à la rencontre de 50 auteurs et 50
librairies indépendantes d'île de france
l'occasion pour eux de découvrir le
monde de la littérature
le reportage d'eléonore sinoquet
bérengère à bourgoin et célia gars
tsongo ce sont 21 élèves qui ont pu
rencontrer à la librairie entre
guillemets à la queue-lez-yvelines
hélène gaudi écrivaine grâce à la
quinzaine de la librairie organisé par
la région ile de france
ces lycéens ont découvert la profession
d'auteur franchement c'était super ça
fait plaisir de rencontrer un auteur
dont apprécié le livre et moi j'ai
apprécié l'histoire et je suis très
contente d'avoir participé à ce projet
moi je les trouvais très intéressant de
bas après avoir lu livre d'avoir le
point de vue de l'auteur en plus du
point de vue que nous on a pu avoir du
livre et d'échanger sur comment est ce
qu elle a ressenti libre
et comparez du coup avec nous et que
peut-être les messages que nous on
n'aurait pas compris en lisant le livre
qu'elle puisse nous les transmettre en
plus c'est que ça complète un peu la
lecture qu'on a eu du livre puisque les
lycéens avant de rencontrer l'écrivaine
ont lu son dernier ouvrage un monde sans
rivage écrit à partir des photos d'une
expédition polaire datant de la fin du
19e siècle puis ils ont travaillé
l'oeuvre sous forme d'écrits d'invention
je pense que pour eux ça rend les choses
concrètes salle et ça les fait
rencontrer les vraiment les écrivains
sur lesquels on travaille voit qu'il ya
une vraie personne derrière un vrai
travail un vrai métier une vraie
recherche pour écrire les livres qu'ils
ont aussi parfois des questions même
matériel sur le métier d'auteur un
moment pour sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'univers de la lecture et un partage
d'idées aussi pour l'écrivain toutes et
tous ils ont vraiment on voit qu'ils se
sont vraiment investis dans cette
histoire que seule façon appropriée et
ça c'est vraiment émouvant et précieux
pour quand on écrit je pense de de voir
que l'histoire lille les images passent
de de notre tête a fait des autres et
que ensuite elles produisent encore
d'autres d'autres textes d'autres images
c'est vraiment très très précieux les
échanges sont importants
l'image de marque est important donc
forcément c'est toujours un plus pour
notre boutique de voile à participer à
ce genre d'organisation d'autres temps
des changes sont prévues dans les
yvelines comme à la librairie comme un
roman à chatou mercredi 26 mai avec le
lycée allant du vésinet ou à la
librairie la suite à versailles avec le
lycée jules ferry de versailles le
vendredi 28 mai et c'est la fin de ce
numéro spécial réouverture des lieux
culturels merci de nous avoir suivis à
très bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]